l'islam c'est les terroristes qui ont
les boys et au québec vous impose par
notre religion tu marches papicha mesure
gars qu'est ce qui est cadenassé ranger
en france la grecque
que ce soit en europe ça s'en vient ici
ici ont même fait des menaces un museau
sur été emmenés par disney serait comme
quoi que c'est bien mieux de faire
attention parce qu'en france ce sont
aussi ces une petite bâtisse et oui oui
et oui et ça c'est l'ennemi n'a jamais
progressé ne ricane l'afp
parce que la religion islamique c'est à
nous la mpt qui est comme ça c'est
certaines personnes de l'islam
jacquemin bombay laisser personne ne
considère ces lieux qu'on veut pas voir
parce qu'après c'est sacré lada est
généralisé alors et qu'il y avait
maintenant à l'islam d'étonnant à ce
qu'ils sont en train de modifier l'islam
parce que c'est passé à l'islam s'est
pas tué des gens l'islam est une
religion depuis un an mais pourquoi je
n'arrive pas du bien à tout le monde moi
je marche même si vous êtes chrétien
vous êtes à tige
je vais être bien je vous sourit je suis
pas là en train de vous dire non parce
que moi mon ma religion m dites vous de
vous de vous tuer ou je sais pas parce
que c'est pas ça que jadis annoncé côté
le monde mais est logiquement à l'islam
la religion la police et au québec c'est
ce qu'on a décidé nous développons la
marche mal que vous dites pas ce qu'ils
vont jamais enlever les musulmans d'ici
et parce que c'est pas ça l'islam c'est
parce que vous êtes en train de dire
parce qu'ils vont jamais le faire si
vous dites non à l'islam ils vont pas
vous dire qu on va enlever tous les
musulmans du canada ça va ça va jamais
arrivés aussi vous voulez que ça fasse
quelque chose
en fait je suis d'accord avec vous aussi
j'aime pas les musulmans qui passe et
qui disent foutu il faut que vous soyez
tous musulmans c'est pas vrai bon parce
que vous allez les gars mais vous c'est
le concept si j'ai mal pris mon ange et
greg nombre d'enregistrements l'écrivain
3 votre annonce va rien faire parce
qu'il votera non non fromont annonce
mais j'ai de la chance
merci beaucoup